thank you to the academy i  who ever thinks they're gonna get to say  that sentence like let alone for their  grad thesis film  i  can't even um i want to give a shout out  to my  young baby self in saudi arabia  whose whole life was movies i always was  like i'm not pretty enough to be an  actress and i didn't think that you know  women got to be directors i was like  where are the women i don't see their  names in any of the credits of these  things and i'm so proud of that little  kid who held on and was like no like i  gotta do this i have to do it i gotta  thank you so much to felicia ferrara and  luke dyra who made it happen thank you  to our entire cast and crew thank you to  my mom and sister who are the best and  thank you to bizoo  the best dog in the world who was  definitely my soul mate  and thank you to the academy again like  that's the wildest sentence in the  history of time